i recently attended a hands-off preview
for pokemon brilliant diamond shining
pearl the upcoming nintendo switch
remakes for the generation 4 games that
initially launched for nintendo ds ahead
of their release for brilliant diamond
shining pearl developer ilca and
publisher nintendo have marketed the
remakes as faithful adaptations of the
original generation 4 games and although
the remakes do look faithful to the
original experience in terms of
structure i got the sense that they
won't feel faithful and i mean that in a
good way based on what i saw it seems
like the mechanical improvements made to
diamond and pearl's formula may
ultimately result in a more approachable
experience i think players are going to
find these games to be a lot easier to
get through than the original diamond
and pearl before we fully dive into the
preview we ask that you hit the
subscribe button it will keep you up to
date on game spots of video coverage
including previews like this one we'd
appreciate a like as well if you end up
enjoying the video now back to pokemon
in terms of overall structure and
presentation yes brilliant diamond
shining pearl are faithful adaptations
of the original diamond and pearl unlike
sword and shield with its
over-the-shoulder perspective
realistically proportioned characters
and occasional free camera moments
brilliant diamond shining pearl is
presented in pokemon's traditional
top-down perspective with a more
chibi-like visual style and no free
camera brilliant diamond shining pearl
looks like an old-school pokemon game
the pokemon center and pokemon are
separate buildings again for example
more notably catching wild pokemon is
once again a mostly random affair while
exploring the overworld you won't see
pokemon running around as you did in the
past few games like in the old days to
find a wild pokemon you'll have to enter
tall grass you surf over water or go
fishing and you won't know what you're
going up against until the fight starts
the one exception to this rule is the
new grand underground which looks
absolutely massive the preview didn't
show off the entire area but i did get a
chance to look at a map for the grand
underground it looks to be a sprawling
assortment of interconnecting caverns in
the grand underground pokemon wander
around and if aggressive chase after you
similar to the wild area and sword and
shield many generation 4 exclusive
features return in brilliant diamond
shining pearl you can bait honey trees
to attract wild pokemon enter enhanced
pokemon contests make poffins to improve
your pokemon's conditions and decorate
pokeball seals with stickers amity park
a place where you can walk around with
your pokemon to strengthen your
relationship with them also returns they
all look to be just as unrewarding as
they were in diamond and pearl but they
all also appear to be just as easily
skippable this time around that's not
where brilliant diamond shining pearl
have made strides in generation 4's
formula these remakes make their most
notable changes in regards to catching
pokemon battling and leveling pokemon
and exploring brilliant diamond shining
pearl bring forward a lot of the
improvements made in pokemon games since
the release of generation 4. some are
purely aesthetic but most are mechanical
changes and those mechanical changes
could domino effect into an altogether
more approachable generation 4
experience hidden machines return in
brilliant diamond shining pearl but
similar to the last few pokemon games
these moves are no longer tied to
pokemon you don't have to give up one of
your pokemon's moves to have it learned
in hm for those who don't know or
remember generation 4 has an hm problem
used to have to regularly carry around
at least two pokemon that collectively
knew cut surf strength rock smash
waterfall and rock climb just to get
through generation four since you no
longer have to do that it should help
you build out a more balanced team and
on top of that it will be easier to grow
the strength of that team thanks to all
pokemon in your party receiving
experience for a fight experience share
is available from the start and applies
to your entire party that's going to be
huge for helping to deal with diamond
and pearl's level pacing issue in
generation 4 you immediately go to fight
the elite foreign champion after
completing all 8 gems there's nothing to
really do in between that's a hard fight
if you don't take the time to grind out
and level all members of your team the
highest level pokemon for the 8th gem is
49 while the champion has a team of
pokemon that are levels
60-66 most generations have a gap in
strength between gem-8 and the champion
but generation 4 is especially tough
given the size of the gap and the team
that the champion uses so you have to
train up your team between the eighth
gym and taking on the elite foreign
champion in the original diamond and
pearl tight matchups are most important
for pokemon battles but an 11 to 17
level difference is significant enough
for the champion to just tank your hits
provided brilliant diamond shining pearl
keep all trainers at the same levels
they were in the original games the
grind between beating the final gem and
taking on the elite foreign champion
should be a lot shorter thanks to that
experience share more than anything
however is that brilliant diamond
shining pearl will incorporate current
pokemon typings that means you'll get
fairy types which didn't exist when
diamond and pearl first launched
bringing a fairy type pokemon into the
back-to-back fights of the elite foreign
champion is huge as some of those
trainers hardest hitters are weak to
fairy type pokemon beyond that brilliant
diamond shining pearl adds a host of
quality of life improvements and auto
safe features should help to make sure
you don't accidentally lose hours of
progress pokemon move info will inform
you whether the attack you want to do
will be effective a button on the battle
screen will quickly pull up the pokeball
page in your bag so you're not
scrounging around through menus when
catching pokemon and a waypoint marker
will let you know where to go to next in
case you're lost there are an assortment
of other changes too like being able to
access your pc pokemon from anywhere as
i mentioned before there are a few
aesthetic improvements the remakes make
as well beyond the obvious updated
graphics and visuals the first is
character customization though i didn't
get to see what options are available
your trainer in brilliant diamond
shining parole can be customized a
member nintendo treehouse of the preview
told us that there are eight ways to
change your character's appearance four
for female four for male and on top of
that each pokemon move has been
reanimated is that every move has its
own animation though i didn't get to see
it i was told hyper beam looks
especially awesome and that's what i saw
all in all the mechanical changes in
these remakes speak to a possibly
altogether smoother far more hassle-free
experience it's obviously too soon to
tell given that we still don't have the
games in our hands that's the sense i
got from watching the game in motion for
a half hour as most of the preview was
spent talking about how brilliant
diamond shining pearl addresses what
players weren't fond of with the
original games so yeah the remakes may
look faithful to the originals but i
think they're going to feel much better
to play we won't have to wait that much
longer to find out seeing as brilliant
diamond shining pearl is scheduled to
launch for nintendo switch on november
19th if you want to stay updated on our
coverage for brilliant diamond shining
pearl be sure to subscribe to gamespot
and like the video if you enjoyed it it
lets us know you want to see more video
previews like this one in fact you can
watch another one of our video previews
right now we recently went hands on with
forza horizon 5 another game slated to
launch this holiday season
[Music]